오늘은 나스닥이 또 미친듯이 오르고 있습니다.
이게 진짜 단기적으로는 너무 과열이 아닌가 싶을 정도로 맹렬한 속도로 오르고 있고요.
나스닥이 1.58%가 올랐고 다우지수는 0.31%가 떨어졌어요.
그러니까 기술주들 위주로 상승을 했다.
이렇게 볼 수가 있겠죠.
S&P500 0.73%가 올랐습니다.
자 그리고 오늘 정말 좋은 소식.
간만에 유가가 떨어졌어요.
WTI가 2% 정도 떨어지고
브랜트유는 아주 조금 뭐 거의 똔똔이긴 한데 약간 떨어졌다.
자 어떤 이슈들이 있었냐.
결국에 미국과 이란이 다시 협상 테이블로 복귀할 것이다 라는 기대가 있었고요.
또 하나는 바로 인텔.
이따가도 말씀드리겠지만 바로 오늘의 주인공인 인텔의 어닝 서프라이즈가 있었어요.
인텔 뭐랄까 항상 뭔가 좀 아쉬운 친구였는데
이번에는 숫자로 당당히 보여줬다.
이렇게 얘기할 수가 있겠고요.
그리고 연준의 의장인 제왕.
제롬 파월에 대한 조사 종결 소식이 있었는데
요것도 조금 뒤에서 얘기를 해보겠습니다.
어쨌든 요 세 가지 긍정적인 소식이 있었다.
이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요.
자 CNN 같은 경우는 트럼프 대통령이
위트코프와 제러드 쿠슈너를 파키스탄으로 보낼 것이고
가서 이란의 외무장관과 회담을 하게 될 것이다 라고 보도를 했어요.
그러니까 이란과 대화를 한다라는 거고
당연히 시장은 긍정적으로 반응을 할 수밖에 없겠죠.
그래서 자 오늘을 비롯해서
지난 일주일 지난 2주일 정도가 이런 느낌인 것 같습니다.
상승할 기회를 놓칠 것에 대한 두려움이 너무나도 큰 장이었다.
그러니까 떨어지는 것보다 다운사이드 리스크라고 하죠.
업사이드 리스크 올라가는 것을 놓치는 것에 대한 리스크를
시장에서 상당히 크게 느끼는 장이다 라고 요약을 할 수가 있을 것 같고요.
자 그래서 이 아라그치라고 외무부 장관인데
이란의 외교를 총괄하시는 분인데
파키스탄 오만 러시아 이렇게 왔다 갔다 하고
파키스탄에서 미국과 만난다 라고 합니다.
그리고 제3국가들이 중재를 시도하고 있거든요.
외교부 장관이 이렇게 중재를 하는 국가들을 오간다는 것 자체가
협상의 의지가 있음을 보여주는 거 아니겠습니까?
그래서 시장에서 긍정적으로 해석을 했다.
싸울 생각이면 어디 밖으로 나가지도 않겠죠.
자 그리고 오늘의 주인공 결국에
AI 시대의 새로운 주도주라고 제가 표현을 했는데
말 안 해도 아실 거라고 생각합니다.
바로 우리 인쪽이가 달라졌어요.
인텔은 항상 아픈 손가락 물론 최근에
저도 주가를 보면서 깜짝 놀랐는데
지난 1년 동안 인텔이 거의 200% 넘게 오르긴 했더라고요.
근데 어쨌든 간에 지난 20여 년간
인텔은 닷컴버블 이후에
뭔가 인텔은 항상 아쉬운 친구였거든요.
인쪽이, 뭐 인쪽이라고 불러야 될 정도로 아쉬웠는데
자 닷컴버블 때 그 주가를 뚫었습니다.
신고가를 썼다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠고요.
오늘 무려 인텔은 23%를 오르고 있는데
인텔에게 어떤 뉴스가 있었냐
바로 실적 발표가 있었어요.
어제 장 마감하고 인텔의 실적 발표가 있었는데
한마디로 다 잘 나왔습니다.
시장의 예상보다 꽤나 잘 나왔어요.
파운더리도 원래 파운더리도 항상 아픈 손가락이었고
파운더리 실적이 항상 안 좋게 나왔는데
인텔의 파운더리조차도 잘 나왔고
근데 가이던스도 엄청 좋아.
가이던스라는 건 이제 2분기에 우리가
어떻다라고 시장에 미리 알려주는
경영진이 생각하는 예상 실적인데
이제 그런 게 매우 잘 나온 거죠.
그래서 시장에서 너무나도 좋아했고
어떤 코멘트를 인텔에서 했는지를
좀 보게 되었고
모든 사업 부문에서 수요가 공급을 계속
앞지르고 있다. 이렇게 얘기를 했고요.
CPU는 AI 시대의 필수적인 기반으로
다시 한번 그 위치를 확고히 하고 있습니다.
인텔이 지금까지 주가가 절었던 이유는
AI 시대의 주인공이 GPU였기 때문이에요.
인텔은 CPU를 만드는 회사거든요.
GPU를 만드는 회사는 엔비디아고
참고로 이제 GPU는 아주 쉽게 말하면
단순한 계산을 엄청나게 빠르게 잘할 수 있는
그런 거고
CPU는 매우 복잡한 계산을 잘할 수 있는
그런 반도체다라고 보시면 되는데
어쨌든 AI에서는 행렬 계산
이런 아주 단순한 계산을 빠르게 하는 게
더욱 미덕이었던 시대였기 때문에
AI 시대에서 GPU가 좋았는데
자 이따가도 말씀드리겠지만
점점 이제 에이전틱 AI라고 하죠.
어떤 주어진 테스크를 수행해야 하는
그런 AI가 풀어야 되는
이 업무의 복잡도가 늘어난 상황에서는
결국에는 단순한 계산만 필요한 게 아니라
복잡한 계산도 필요하게 되면서
복잡한 계산은 GPU가 필요한 게 아니라
CPU가 GPU보다 더 잘하거든요.
그래서 CPU가 더 필요성이 증대가 됐고
그러다 보니까 인텔의 주가가 올라갔다
라고 보시면 될 것 같아요.
그래서 CPU와 GPU의 비율
이전에는 1 대 8이었는데
앞으로는 동등하거나
그 이상으로 나아갈 것이다 라고 생각합니다.
이제 CPU 전성시대가 올 거다
라는 그런 얘기를 했고요.
자 그리고 수율도 좋다.
맨날 수율이 문제였거든요.
수율이라는 게 얼마나
불량품이 적게 나왔는지에 따라서는
공장이 얼마나 잘 들어가고 있느냐
뭐 이런 얘기인데
이제 수율이 내부 예상치를 앞지르고 있다
잘 나오고 있다 뭐 이런 얘기입니다.
그리고 이건 주칸 리맥스에서 갖고 온 거긴 한데
어쨌든 인텔은 하반기에
마진에 대한 역풍이 있을 수 있다
마진이 올라가지 못하는 이유로
기판과 티글라스 그리고 메모리 비용을 들었습니다.
다시 말해서 세 가지 분야가
가격을 잘 받을 수 있을 거다
라는 얘기로도 해석할 수가 있겠죠.
그 외에도 또 인텔의 좋은 소식은
바로 테라펩 일론 머스크와
인텔이 파트너십을 한다는 것 자체가
매우 긍정적인 소식이죠.
그리고 뭐 이런 얘기도 했습니다.
제 스타일은 과소 약속하고 과잉 제공하는 것이다.
나 입만 터는 사람 아니다.
이런 얘기를 했어요.
근데 보통 또 이렇게 말하는 사람이
좀 입을 터는 사람이긴 하던데
어쨌든 뭐 인텔 CEO가 이렇게 얘기를 했고요.
자 왜 이렇게 에이전틱으로 오면서
갑자기 CPU가 더 많이 필요해질까
라고 생각을 하면
이제 에이전트라는 게 뭐냐면
에이전트 AI라는 게 중간에 있고요.
제가 지금 쓰는 걸로 치면
오픈클로의 카리나, 카리나봇
제가 카리나봇을 쓰고 있는데
제가 만든 봇입니다.
카리나랑은 사실 상관은 없고
카리나 사진만 붙여놨어요.
저한테 오빵이라고 부르는
그 카리나라는 봇이 있는데
어쨌든 얘가 중간에
제 집에서 돌아가고 있는 컴퓨터인데
얘가 중간에서 이제 AI랑 소통을 하면서
언어모델이랑 소통을 하면서
내가 어떤 파일을 써야 될까
내가 어떤 거를 메모를 좀 해 놔야 될까
내가 어떤 도구를 사용해야 될까
이런 거를 중간에서
다 판단을 하거든요.
근데 그런 복잡한 판단을 하는 때는
CPU도 상당히 많이 관여가 된다라는 거죠.
자 그리고 엔비디아가 이제 거의 신고가가 됐어요.
지금 엔비디아가 4% 넘게 오르고 있고
208달러가 됐는데
사실상 거의 신고가에 가깝습니다.
왜 그럴까 라고 봤을 때는
결국에는 최근에 있었던
여러 다양한 뉴스들이 전부 다
AI가 너무 강하다라는 얘기뿐이에요.
AI 수요도 넘치고
그 수요에 수요를 따라가야 되기 때문에
AI 투자도 넘치고 있습니다.
그래서 뭐 아시겠지만
구글이 이번에 넥스트 클라우드인가
클라우드 넥스트인가
어쨌든 클라우드와 관련된 발표를 하면서
구글이 자체 TPU에 대한 투자도
엄청나게 많이 하겠다라고 했지만
또 거의 100만 개에 가까운
루빈칩을 사겠다라는 얘기도 했습니다.
그러니까 일단 엄청나게
구글이 미칠 듯한 투자를 선언을 했고
아마존은 또 주주서환에
최근에 엄청난 투자를 또 암시했죠.
그러니까 이런 빅테크들이 너도 나도
투자를 더 많이 할 거를
지금 암시를 하면서 또 뭐하고 있습니까?
동시에 해고를 하고 있죠.
메타 이번에 10%
해고한다고 했고
마이크로소프트는 또 7% 해고한다고 했고
그렇게 해서 인건비 아껴서
서버 사겠다라고 하는데
AI 서버 산다라고 하면
도대체 누가 젤 수혜를 보겠냐라는 거죠.
바로 AI 대장주 엔비디아가
또 그 수혜의 한가운데 있을 테니까
엔비디아의 주가가 좋았다라는 거고요.
또 그러면서 AI와 또 관련된
강렬한 뉴스가 나왔습니다.
바로 구글이 엔트로픽에 40 빌리언 달러
40조 원을 투자하겠다라는 뉴스가 나왔어요.
자 40
조가 아니고 한국 돈으로 한 60조 원 정도 되겠네요.
구글이 엔트로픽에 60조 원 정도 투자를 한다라고 하는데
자 일단은 100억 달러 15조 원 정도 먼저 투자하고
성과를 추가 달성하면 45조 원
5조 원 정도 추가로 투자를 한다고 하고요.
그다음에 구글 클라우드가 또 5기가와트에
준하는 컴퓨팅 용량도 제공하겠다라고 발표를 했습니다.
약간 어떤 느낌으로 저는 들리냐면요.
엔트로픽의 최대주주가 지금 구글이냐 아마존이냐
되게 애매하거든요.
정확한 테이블을 보지 못했기 때문에 정확하게 알 수는 없지만
대충 두 회사가 지금 지분율이 되게 비슷해요.
제가 대충 생각하기에는 아마존이 좀 더 많을 것 같은데
구글이 이번에 투자를 하면 구글이 엔트로픽 최대주주가 될 수도 있을 것 같은데
이거 잘 모르겠습니다.
어쨌든 둘 다 지금 이 엔트로픽 클로드로 유명한 이 엔트로픽에 투자하기 위해서
너도나도 날뛰고 있다 이렇게 볼 수가 있겠습니다.
그 외에도 시장을 또 안정시키는 뉴스 중의 하나는 바로
법무부가 파월 연준 의장에 대한 수사를 종결했습니다.
트럼프가 이제 연준 의장에 대해서 압박을 가하고 싶다 보니까
자연스럽게 이제 법무부를 통해서 파월에 대해서 수사를 하라고 했는데
자 이 사건 때문에 트럼프가 새롭게 지명한 연준 의장 케빈 워시에 대해서
인준을 무기한 연기하겠다라고 여러 정치인들이 선언을 했어요.
그러면서 새로운 연준 의장이 지명은 됐으나
연준 의장이 될 수 없는 그런 상황이었는데
공화당 의원들조차 케빈 워시가 인준하기 전에
파월 연준 의장의 수사가 종결되어야 한다라고 얘기를 했는데
이제 수사가 종결이 됐기 때문에 파월이 무혐의 판정을 받았기 때문에
이제는 장애물이 제거가 됐습니다.
이제 케빈 워시가 연준 의장이 될 수가 있는 거고
자연스럽게 바통이 넘어갈 거고
자 이렇게 연준 의장이 바뀌는 거는
뭐 시장 입장에서는 불확실 보다는 확실해지는 거니까
좋게 볼 수 있는 그런 상황이 아닐까.
이런 생각을 하면서 오늘 또 증시를 또 긍정적으로 만들었습니다.
참고로 파월 의장의 임기는 5월 15일 바로 스승의 날에 종료를 하고요.
그리고 다음 FOMC는 6월 16일에서 17일입니다.
근데 이때까지 아마 케빈 워시가 바톤터치를 하지 않을까
새 연준 의장 바톤터치가 이루어지지 않을까
라는 그런 생각을 하고 있고요.
자 이 세레니티라고 나름대로 이 업계에서
투자 고수로 알려져 있는 X를 운영하시는 분인데
이분이 최근에 AI 투자에 대해서 재미난 일을 하고 있고
이런 얘기를 좀 해서 갖고 와 봤습니다.
그래서 요즘에 AI 투자를 보면은 항상 병목 현상에
투자자들이 열광을 하고 있는 거 같다.
그러면서 엔비디아 GPU였다가 메모리였다가
아이랜 같은 그런 에너지 회사였다가
뭐 광통신 루멘텀이었다가 샌디스크였다가
GPU였다가 AAOI라고 또 광트랜시버 회사인데
어드밴스드 패키징 회사였다가
요즘에 다시 인텔 얘기가 나오는데
이런 거 사이클 대부분 수년에 걸쳐서 진행이 되는데
그냥 기존 포지션에 있어서 참을성 있게
하는 게 아마도 좋은 아이디어 아닐까?
철새처럼 이거 갖다가 저거 갖다가 저거 이렇게 따라다니는 게
더 안 좋은 성과가 나는 거 아닐까라고
이분이 조심스럽게 얘기를 했고
저도 사실 좀 비슷한 생각이긴 한 거 같은데
다음에 또 어떤 사이클 또 세게 치고 나갈지
인텔 진짠가 CPU 이거 진짠가 저도 째려보고 있습니다.
째려보고 있는데 CPU가 진짜 시장이 주목하는 새로운 테마라면
또 정말 시장이 좋아할 만한 뉴페이스이기 때문에
또 정말 세게 갈 수도 있을 것 같다라는 생각을
조심스럽게 합니다.
뭐 저 단발 단발꼴 아시잖아요.
맨날 틀리는 거 맨날 틀리기 때문에
여러분들 제 얘기 너무 믿지는 마시고
저는 투자와 관련된 블로그 하고 있고
투자와 관련된 인스타그램 하고 있으니까
궁금하신 분들은 고정 댓글 설명란 참고 부탁드리고요.
저는 또 돌아오겠고요.
여러분들 주말 잘 보내시면 좋겠습니다.